now Xi Jinping has said many times that
this Century humiliation will be
overcome by the Chinese people and that
they'll take every square inch of
property back that they believe was
theirs that they believe was
historically Chinese you know this idea
that they're gonna that China is going
to assemble all this land that it lost
to Western powers or it lost when it was
humiliated because it was weak do you
think they're not coming for the Russian
[Music]
lands
hello everyone watching and listening
today I have the pleasure of speaking
with Ambassador Robert
O'Brien we discussed the inner workings
of international hostage negotiations
the ongoing success and Legacy of the
Abraham Accords negotiated under
President Trump the Russia Ukraine war
and its complexities and the current
perception of
diminished American strength a situation
which leaves much room for
improvement so Ambassador O'Brien you
were the fourth US security adviser
under Donald Trump so why were you the
fourth and what was it like taking on
the job knowing you were the fourth and
what was it like working with me he's a
mystery to many people maybe he's a
mystery to himself who knows but but you
stepped into a role that had obviously
been contentious and so there must have
been some
apprehension in that
regard why did you do it and what was
that like well thanks Jordan great to be
with you uh you know I was the fourth we
had General Flynn was there for a brief
period of time and then General master
and John Bolton it's not a job I
expected to receive but I was serving as
the president's hostage Envoy at the
time trying to bring Americans home from
uh detention or uh wrongful Det
attention or being held hostage by
terrorist organizations and I didn't
really know the president I I'd been
with another candidate in 2016 Scott
Walker the governor of
Wisconsin and uh but I I supported the
president in the general election of
course and uh he asked me to be the
hostage Envoy and I got to know him
through that job we I think one of the
things president Trump appreciated about
the work I did is we got a lot of
Americans home and president Trump gets
the credit for that some people give me
credit for it and that's flattering but
you know when things go well for a
president the President should get the
credit and he deserved the credit for
bringing these many Americans home and
so we developed a relationship I I was
actually in Israel working on a hostage
case trying to help some the Israelis
bring a the remains of a a fallen
soldier home and uh John Bolton had
resigned or was fired depending on Whose
story you believe and uh uh I got the
call to come in for an interview and uh
interviewed at the president went well
and uh he asked me to to do the job so I
was you know humbled and honored to to
have that position I didn't know you
know I I was keenly aware that I was a
fourth person but I also felt that I had
a good relationship with the president
and I felt my job every day and the
prayer I said as I left the my apartment
every morning was that we'd keep America
safe that day and I think the president
appreciated my commitment to keeping the
country safe and I appreciated his
commitment to to doing this doing the
same and we had a good relationship and
uh it worked out well we had a lot of
lot of accomplishments that took place
that last year and a half in in office
so let's talk about the the hostage
cases to begin with so um how did you
get involved in doing that and then do
you want to walk us through some of the
stories and and and what it is exactly
that you were doing before you became US
security adviser and how that set you up
for the job sure so I received a call in
late
2017 uh from the White House asking if
I'd be willing to fill this role of
being the US hostage Envoy the the title
is spha which sounds like a Dr Seuss
character
but it's it's an acronym for special
presidential Envoy for hostage
Affairs and I just started a law firm
with a a partner Steven Larson a former
federal judge in Los Angeles we left a
big National firm and so I wasn't
planning on going into government uh but
I always
wondered over my career I've spent time
traveling abroad uh all over the world
in international arbitration cases and
and law cases I always kind of wondered
if our plan was hijacked if if we taken
hostage would someone come look for us
and when when the job was uh was offered
I went and talked to my wife and we we
prayed about it we looked at some of the
cases of people who were held abroad and
I thought you know I'm going to I'm
going to give this a shot and it's a a
sacrifice for the family and a sacrifice
for my law Partners but uh I'm going to
go see if I can get some people home and
uh we did the job and we got a lot of
people home we were very successful at
it again credit for that goes to the
president for his tough stand on on
bringing Americans home he I think he
felt that Americans being held abroad
just because they were Americans just
because they h a blue passport was kind
of the essence of of poking your your
your finger in the eye of the United
States and and his America First view of
the world was if you do that I don't
care who the person is how why they were
taken if they were a missionary if they
were a tourist if they were a business
person a diplomat a soldier uh if you've
taken somebody to leverage them uh
leverage their life to try and get the
US to change our policy or try and get a
concession from us or money from us uh
we're not going to stand for it and
we're going to get that person home and
so that that was a job I undertook and
uh it would you know didn't expect it to
lead to becoming the National Security
adviser but again we had some success
and I can talk to you about some of the
cases and uh and and again I think at
the end of the day the president gets
the credit for making it a high priority
and uh you know you you're up against a
bureaucracy other people in government
have different priorities and getting
getting a single American home but but
for me my job was solely focused on in
that position was solely focused on
bringing these Americans home so what
had set you up in your previous career
to be able to conduct those negotiations
and why do you think that you were apart
from Trump's support which we can go
into what why do you what do you think
it was that made you successful at doing
this and what was it like to actually
negotiate who are you negotiating with
and what was that like how did you do it
yeah so so great questions the uh you
know I think my past experience as a
diplomat I'd been a diplomat in the Bush
Administration and uh and had even
carried over and working on an Afghan
Afghanistan program for uh uh the cony
rice setup but went into the Obama
Clinton uh years when secretary Clinton
was Secretary of State uh that that
certainly helped I'd been a army officer
earlier in my career and had worked at
the UN so I had kind of the Diplomatic
experience but I think the day-to-day
experience of being a lawyer in Los
Angeles I I was a litigator and you know
we've got the toughest uh toughest
lawyers in the country I think in in La
uh and spent a lot of time in mediations
hundreds of mediations over my career
both serving as Council for parties but
also then later serving as an arbitrator
a mediator and a neutral I think that
was the the experience that gave me the
the the the best uh background for the
job as hostage Envoy and then to your
question about who do we negotiate with
it was you know it's tough because you
know we couldn't negotiate directly with
some of these countries for example the
Iranians you know I had to work through
the Swiss uh so we our inors were the uh
the Swiss diplomats who are great
diplomats and uh we worked with them we
worked with other third party
governments to to get to governments
that we could negotiate with uh
negotiated with the Russians directly we
negotiated with the Taliban directly and
you've got a you know you've got bad
guys on the other side you've got thugs
on the other side to you know to some
extent and you've got to be tough and uh
and that has to be backed up by American
hard power the diplomacy is important
the negotiating skills are important but
at the end of the day they're looking at
you to see you know what's America going
to do if we if we don't comply what what
tools does this guy have in his in his
toolkit what kind of support is he going
to get from the
bureaucracy and that that goes back to
the classic Ronald Reagan formulation of
Peace for strength so working for a
president who believed in peace through
strength who didn't you know wasn't
trying to appe or or not provoke the our
adversaries but who who believed in a
strong America and that a strong America
was good for for peace in the world that
that helped me in my negotiations so you
know that was uh giv that in the
thumbnail the other thing I did Jordan
which I think was uh created a stir at
the time when I became the hostage Envoy
there was a memo about the office that
had been prepared in the prior
Administration and the Obama
Administration that described what we
did as the office of the spha and it
said our our first Resort is diplomacy
and the very last resort we'll take to
rescue Americans is military force and I
looked at that and I said this is
exactly wrong and I changed the memo I
said our first Resort will be to use our
military our special operators and our
special operations Community was really
the modern Special Operations Community
was formed after the failed attempt to
rescue American diplomats held in Iran
in 1980 and that's that's how we ended
up with Delta Force and Seal Team 6 and
and it's this very top tier group of
operators they originally set up to be
hostage rescue guys based in a large
part on the SAS and the UK the SAS
regimen and so I said look our first
Resort if we can if we can affect Rescue
is we're going to use these highly
trained you know National Assets these
great men and women US Special Forces to
go get our hostages back or our wrongful
detes back and then we'll look at
diplomatic options and I wanted to send
a message to our adversaries that you
know we're gonna this is a different
approach and uh we're going to use
American hard power and so you know if
you've got a chance to negotiate with us
or negotiate with a third party country
that's coming to you on our behalf take
it because you know the the other option
we've got and our primary option is to
go rescue our people and uh we had a
number of rescues that uh either
using foreign partner forces that engage
special operators of foreign governments
or our own special operators that were
really Exquisite where we brought
Americans home and I think that sent a
message to folks and backed up our
diplomacy uh so so that was one thing
that we did to to kind of change the
policy and at least send a message to
our our foreign adversaries and the
terrorist organizations or or Rogue
governments that if you take an American
there's a there's a penalty to pay and
and we're going to get them back okay so
to get so if I get this straight so the
people that were taking hostages came to
know that they might have an opportunity
to
negotiate through the intermediation of
third parties but that the military
option was likely to be brought forward
very rapidly is that the right sequence
of
events
correct and and look if if we had a
military oper operation that could be
launched immediately short you know it
it becomes more difficult to launch
these operations if a hostage is aged if
they've been taken and been held for a
while because they're they're moved and
the some of the terrorist organizations
have pretty good operational security
it's always tougher when a government is
holding your hostage because you know
they'll help a downtown jail and
somewhere in Caracus or Teran or Moscow
so th those those circumstances make the
military option more difficult uh but if
we could find uh a hostage organization
we did this at the end of the
administration in late October in 2020 a
group had kidnapped an American named
Walton in in ner uh we launched an
operation within 48 Hours rescued them
uh you know dealt with a terrorist
rescued him brought him home safely and
uh and the whole thing happened in a
very short period of time I think that
from from start to finish it was a
72-hour operation from us finding and
fixing where he was where the terrorists
had him the kidnappers and and bringing
him back to Washington DC so sometimes
you know NE negotiations weren't always
an option but it was for for the bad
guys but uh if they if they' secured the
hostage somewhere they a government had
him in in a jail that was certainly you
know that that was one course for them
to take right right so were there any
downsides to moving the military option
up the list of priorities did that add
risk in any situations or do you think
overall it and in the specifics it
decreased
risk well I think overall it decreased
risk right because it you you you let
people know that if you if you take an
American hostage uh the the mil US
military is coming for you we've got
Long Reach we can go from you know Fort
Brag uh North Carolina to uh to wherever
you are in a very short period of time
but uh and so we think it was a
deterrent uh and and prevented further
hostage taking but any anytime you put
the men and women of our of our Armed
Force you know into an operation there's
risk to them there's obviously risk to
the hostage and rescue situation where
you know bullets are flying
so you know and there's also a risk of
you know an escalation so that you know
a hostage rescue turns into more of a
conflict but our our our feeling was
that the the deterrent effect of of
letting folks know we're going to rescue
our our people and and the the the high
degree of skill and capability our our
special operators had to to rescue a
hostage if they were taken uh outweighed
the the risk of either escalation or or
or death to one of our service members
or the hostage but it's a you know those
are tough calls to
make well there's going to be risks no
matter what what approach you take has
the has the approach that you put in
place Place stayed
intact as a consequence of the
transition to the Biden Administration
or or what's happened what's happened
now well we have a really terrific uh
hostage Envoy the guy who took over from
me is a guy named Roger Carson's
Ambassador and he was a former military
Special Operations guy I've got a lot of
confidence in him uh but again he's
working in an environment that uh you
know is more of a what I call it don't
do not provoke appe Pease uh mentality
of the the the Obama folks who came and
and have now staffed the Biden
Administration and and I think there's a
lot less emphasis on hard power and a
lot more emphasis on on just pure
diplomacy and soft power and that and
and you know look that that can work in
some cases you know you have different
Tools in your toolkit but I I think
there's a perception of American
weakness now and I I I think that makes
the job of the hostage onvoy tougher but
I think Roger's done a great job and and
to his credit I think the current
national security adviser Jake suvan who
took my position my final position has
been good on these hostage issues but
again you're only so good as the
environment that's around you and and if
your adversaries know that you know
military force is off the table and and
the likelihood of appeasement or Ransom
or concession is on the table they're
going to look for those uh you know
results instead of just turning over the
hostage and hoping that they don't get
punished for for having engaged in mign
activity and do you think that that's
reflected in the broader
geopolitical landscape especially in
relationship to say what's happened in
Ukraine with the Russians look sadly
that sadly that's the case Jordan I mean
we we we saw a direct line from this
catastrophic withdrawal from Afghanistan
and the way that it was handled to
Vladimir Putin sensing that America was
weak and American weakness is
provocative you know American strength
keeps peace in the world but when when
our adversaries believe us to be weak
they they take chances and they take
they look for opportunities to exploit
that weakness and and I don't think
America is fundamentally weaker than we
were four years ago we're we're a very
strong country we've got GE geography on
our side we got demography on our side
we've got Innovation we've got a
tremendous military but the perception
by by from our that our adversaries
develop over time watching things like
Afghanistan watching the failure to
deter Putin
in Ukraine I mean you recall Jordan all
the talk with the pundits and the the
administration folks before Putin's
invasion was we don't want to provoke
them we don't want to give the
ukrainians extra weapons we don't want
to you know do things that would
dissuade the Russians because that could
provoke Putin into an
invasion dictators look at the world
very differently than we do it's not a
rational it's maybe rational from their
perspective but it's not how what we
believe is rational I mean I remember
commentators saying it would be crazy
for Putin to invade Ukraine well Putin
didn't do that way Putin saw us withdraw
from Afghanistan he sensed weakness he
thought he had an opportunity to gain
geography to gain territory he's got a
demographic problem in Russia he could
gain 40 million more Russians uh he
could get access to agricultural land
and and increases Russia's ability to
trade Ukraine has some uh natural
resources some oil and gas so he looked
at that as an opportunity to take the
whole thing whereas we would think
that's irrational for a big country just
to invade its neighbor because it could
because might makes right but for Putin
it was perfectly IR rational and so when
he sensed our weakness he moved and uh
and we didn't do a good job to turn them
and that was a failure of of policy now
we've done a pretty good job supplying
the ukrainians since then since the
invasion but we we we lost a real
opportunity to prevent the whole war
from happening and that that that was a
shame for the Ukrainian people and and
frankly for the Russian
people we talk about pre-born a lot on
our shows here at the daily wire we
believe in their mission and we know you
do too who wouldn't want to help mothers
and their children in crisis preborn is
reaching into the hearts of women by
allowing them to hear the heart hearts
of their babies and introducing them to
their precious lives it's a Divine
connection that doubles as a baby's
chance at life every day pre-born
network of clinics rescues 200 babies
lives but it doesn't stop there your
gift of $28 for a free ultrasound goes
directly to Women in Need and pre-born
doesn't take any of that money they
independently fundraise for their team
to continue to make a difference they
offer mothers maternity clothes doctor's
visits and the help they need all gifts
are tax deductible and will go directly
towards saving babies lives to donate
just dial P250 and say the keyword baby
that's P 250 baby or donate securely at
pre-born
docomo that's preborn dcom
Jordan well it was very interesting to
me I mean Trump's a very complicated
character in the US is a very
complicated country in a complicated
world it was very interesting to me
though especially having contemplated
Trump's Legacy in the intervening years
that when he first emerged on the scene
some of the fears associated with him
were that in his sort of bullying and
provocative manner that he'd be a real
bull in the china shop on the foreign
policy side of things
but he seemed capable of simultaneously
Charming
people like Putin and the leader of
North Korea well
simultaneously keeping them on their
heels I would say maybe as a consequence
of his perceived unpredictability but
also his clear willingness perhaps to
use force and the consequence of that
and there's two consequences of that
that I find quite
fascinating it's sort of reminiscent to
me of what happened with reag when he
bombed Gaddafi you know I was pretty
young when that occurred and when Reagan
bombed Gaddafi I thought oh my God all
hell's going to break loose there's
going to be terrorism everywhere because
I mean I think Reagan if I remember
correctly killed a couple of members of
Gaddafi's immediate family in that
bombing raid and I thought all hell was
going to break loose but what happened
instead was that Gaddafi was actually
chastened and the degree of terrorist
activity emanating from Libya declined
to pretty much zero and then when Trump
took power I think one of his remarkable
achievements and I really think that he
has got far less credit for this than he
deserved was that there was a period of
four years without with no Wars like no
Wars and that's pretty damn rare and
there's always some chronic irritating
conflict going on I mean Afghanistan was
continuing but Trump didn't start that
um and also he initiated the Abraham
records even though the Obama
administration had had an opportunity to
do so it was Trump who moved on it it
took a while but he did it successfully
and that could have obviously been
expanded the Abraham Accords they could
have been expanded under Biden the
Saudis as far as I can tell would have
signed those Accords if Biden would have
taken the opportunity that was right
bloody well in front of them to take and
so we have this strange spectacle of
someone who's pretty blustery and noisy
and and who might easily be regarded as
provocative actually setting up a
circumstance where by your testimony the
negotiation for hostages was much more
likely to be successful but also where
there were no incursions of the sort say
that Russia undertook in Ukraine during
that four-year period that would
precipitate a war and we also saw the
initiation of a a really large scale and
major peace process because that's
certainly what the Abraham Accords
represent so what do you make of all
that well so Jordan you're you're P you
you had a very perceptive uh comment at
the at the outset of that question and
that was how could president Trump be
cordial with some of these B bad guys
and yet still obtain the the results
that uh that we wanted as America to
we're under our national interest and to
deter these these Thugs and and uh
dictators and tyrants from from engaging
in Mali activity and you know there's an
old saying that uh diplomacy is saying
the nastiest possible things in the
nicest possible way and and president
Trump was really a genius at that he he
was always very cordial in his
conversations with with allies but also
with with Putin or or Kim jennan or uh
XI jingping those I was on many of those
phone calls he was very cordial got
along well with them but at the same
time we were sanction we put more
sanctions on the Russians than anybody
since Ronald Reagan I we we put the
Russians in a box and yet the president
was very cordial with them uh and so
they understood here's a guy who's being
cordial wanting to reduce the risk of a
nuclear war in the case with Russia
wanting to make sure that we got our
message
across but at the same time this is a
tough guy who's who's not going to take
any nonsense from us and there was a
level of unpredictability and the
president talked about this that you
know what the odds of us sending troops
to Ukraine were small if Russia invaded
But there was a risk there and Putin had
to take that risk into account it
complicated the lives of his planners
his military planners to say what if
what if Trump does engage then we lose
and that could be a disaster so we
better you know factor that into the
risk and and not not invade Ukraine so
the the same thing happened with with
North Korea and the president had very
cordial relations with with Kim jonun
but it didn't start out that way and and
I I was a hostage Envoy at the time and
when we were talking about Little Rocket
Man and fire and fury and uh my my my
button's bigger than your button but it
wasn't just the rhetoric and this is
what American politic I OB often times
Miss it's backing up the rhetoric with
with hard power so the president moved
two aircraft carriers into the Y yellow
C into the near near North Korea and
said look you want to keep playing this
game I've got you know 80 aircraft per
per carrier and and you a good chunk of
the US Navy sitting off your
Coast how how do you want to do this
would you rather have a summit and try
and work things out and denuclearise now
we obviously didn't get there but we we
went down that path and we and Kim Jan
committed to dlear Iz ation we didn't
get there but but he at least he
committed to it or or do you want to do
you want to keep testing your nuclear
weapons and see how it works out for you
and so it was that combination of
cordiality and and frankness and and you
know uh good cheer with our adversaries
with our partners as well but backing it
up with American hard power and letting
them know that you know if you cross a
line and we're not going to be like
Obama we're not going to set red lines
that we don't intend to enforce but if
we set a red line no it's going to be
enforced so you you understand what
you're getting into that's your call
that's not on us and and that that
raises a very important point that you
made president Trump was the first
president since Jimmy Carter technically
probably argue Reagan as well that
didn't start a new war we didn't send
you know we we eliminated some of the
great terrorist threats to the country
we got baghdaddy uh we took other
measures to protect the country but we
didn't start a new war and and the
reason we didn't start a new war is the
same reason Ronald Reagan didn't start a
new war is because our ADV Aries
understood if we cross American red
lines if we if we damage American
national interests there's going to be a
heavy price to pay and and and we better
factor that into our our our planning
our consideration and and so they didn't
engage in the activity that would have
led to us having to engage militarily
and so the last president that really
truly did that was Ronald Reagan now he
had the Invasion of Grenada but I I'd
argue that was more of a the big hostage
Rescue of the of the medical students in
Grenada that turned into a you know
taking over the the the country but uh
but other than Reagan in recent
presidencies Republican and Democrat no
one has been able to stop our
adversaries without engaging in military
action on a large scale until president
Trump and I think that's one of the
great accomplish great accomplishment of
his administration I wonder if that
proclivity that Trump has to strike
Terror and disarray into the hearts of
his political opponents within the US
who seem to regard him as you know the
next best thing to Satan himself in
terms of the danger he presents to the
Integrity of the state I wonder if that
is the same
unpredictability and
Menace cordial Menace
that inhib that intimidates his
potential opponents or the potential
opponents of the US on the foreign
policy side you think that's the same
manifestation
you know I'm not sure if it's
intimidation I mean he whether it was
our allies we had you know pretty
competent and and and uh confident
leaders like mcon in France or Boris
Johnson in the UK uh Angela Merkel had a
very different personality but was a
very strong character uh and then our
adversaries you know Putin's a tough guy
and Xi Jinping is a tough guy and Kim
janun is you know unpredictable himself
so I'm not sure if it was an
intimidation of the the leaders but I
think what it was is it was the resolve
that he showed and they understood that
this this guy represents America and
sometimes we look at our adversaries and
think they're 10 feet tall and sometimes
our adversaries get ahead of us and we
got to catch up with them China's gotten
ahead of us on a couple of things where
we got to catch up with them but the
reality is America is a fundamentally
very strong country and if you've got a
president that's willing to use all the
tools of American National Power
economic diplomatic military and is is
resolved to protect our national
interest and the other guy guys know
that they they can they can do an
assessment of of the uh you know the
balance of forces and and decide are
they are they going to win or lose if
they press the issue and and I think
with President Trump they understood at
the end of the day this guy had a lot of
backbone and wasn't going to fold and so
they better not cross the red line so
I'm not sure if it's intimidation or you
know more a confidence that uh the
president shows when he enters into a
room and and look that works with
adversaries but it also works with our
partners so one of the Great
accomplishments of the Trump
Administration that that's iner to the
benefit of Ukraine today and and Europe
today is back in 2019 I had I had been
National Security advisor very long
maybe a couple months and we had a real
problem with NATO the president was very
unhappy that our NATO Partners weren't
paying 2% of their GDP with the
exception of not I think at the time it
was four or five countries UK was one of
them Greece the baltics uh turkey but
the rest of the countries were getting a
free ride on American defense and we're
spending three and a half to four % of
our economy of our GDP to defend not
only America but the Free World and the
president said hey that's not right
everyone committed to at least 2% that's
still half of what we're paying but you
got to pay the 2% and the Europeans kind
of chuckled and said well every
president I I went back and looked at
this I actually wrote an article about
it every president running for president
since 1972 the theme has been one of the
campaign planks has been on on both the
Republican and the Democrat side is
Europe will pay its fair share you know
Europe will step up for its own
and no one got it even my you know my
hero Ronald Reagan couldn't get the
Europeans to pay the their Fair Share
Bear their fair fair portion of the
burden and president Trump made some
pretty tough comments about NATO and I
thought wow you know I'm a big NATO
supporter and it's a great Alliance it's
kept the peace in in Europe for many
years 75
years and so I thought how is this going
to play out but it gave me the
opportunity to go as you know The
Negotiator with Yen stoltenberg the
Secretary General of NATO who's a
terrific Statesmen and Yen and I were
able to go to to our Allied partners and
say look the the days of of Germany you
know getting cheap minerals from Russia
selling expensive finished goods to
China and letting America pay for its
defense while it runs up a budg of
surplus that's just not fair that's
that's got to end it's not fair to the
American taxpayer it's not fair to your
other partner Nations and it wasn't just
Germany it was you know Canada was all
the countries and so the fact that
President Trump was being tough and
talking about you know Article 5 apply
uh you know if you're not paying your
dues quot so to speak I mean they
weren't dues but you know that's the way
the president phrased it uh that that
that kind of struck some fear into the
hearts of of our allies so we walked
away with that from that Summit with
going from four or five countries paying
2% to 11 countries paying 2% of their
GDP committing to it but we also had an
overall increase and you know we didn't
get Germany as high as we wanted but we
got a small increase from Germany but
because the German economy was so big it
made it was a lot of money we got $400
billion in commitments for new NATO
spending outside of the us over the
course of 10 years that that December
Summit and of course the hand ringers
the The Diplomatic correspondents and
you know the the you know the the folks
that cover the state department and
cover NATO they they rang their hands
and said this is terrible and it's it's
awful diplomacy and the the standing of
America has gone down in the world well
yeah I'm sure our European allies
weren't weren't happy in some cases that
they had to spend the money but guess
what they're happy now I was at a
conference in Prague recently uh a
defense conference and I had Germans
coming up to me saying you guys were
right thank you for making us spend more
money and that that additional spending
even in the initial three years from 19
to
2022 allowed some of those European
countries to get new platforms and new
weapon systems so that when Russia
invaded Ukraine a lot of those countries
were able to send their old Soviet
equipment especially in Eastern Europe
their old equipment that was no longer
they modernized and they they go went to
a stock pilc and they sent that
equipment to Ukraine and so a lot of the
initial equipment that Ukraine Got was a
direct result of the the additional
incre the increase in defense funding
that came out of that 2019 Summit that
President Trump was pillared for for
being you know arrogant and rude and you
know putting America First and that sort
of thing and in fact what we did is we
put our allies in a position where they
could defend themselves and help Ukraine
and so again it's counterintuitive you
know someone taking that that sort of an
approach uh and it's it's not something
that it may be grading people and and
and diplomats might not like it but when
you look at the results they were
incredibly successful what do you think
it is in Trump's character that makes
him it possible for him to do those
things because that is it's quite a
track record really of success right
because you've laid out four different
instances you said he was very effective
in relationship to hostage
negotiation he was good at keeping
potential enemies at Bay and established
peace for four years but he
also he is he he successfully negotiated
the abrahamic course which will turn to
but as you pointed out and this is this
is quite orthogonal to those other
Enterprises he was instrumental and
successful in getting the NATO allies to
pay their fair share which was something
I was watching that from the outside
from the Canadian perspective and I know
certainly full well that we haven't
pulled our weight at all and continue to
not do so but it was quite striking to
me that he was able to manage that the
Justice of the cause seemed self-evident
I mean it's completely absurd that
America has to shoulder this burden by
itself and also take all the moral
slings and arrows that go along with
being the prime defender of the West
right it's it's just too much to be
asked to pay the financial price and
then to Bear the moral you know appropri
at the same time there's no excuse for
that but Trump was very effective at
negotiating for that to be rectified and
so what do you think it is about his
character and the way he conducts
himself that makes him capable of doing
those things you talked about you know
his his willingness to rely on military
force say in relationship to potential
foreign enemies but of course that's not
going to be an issue when he's talking
to NATO allies so what's he doing right
well look I think I I didn't know
president Trump before becoming his
hostage Envoy and I got to know him a
little bit during that period of time
and then you know came to know him
fairly well as his National Security
advisor but I think it's your background
you know we all bring whatever our
background is to the new job right you
know you're you've got a background as a
clinical psychologist now you're doing
you know political analysis which is you
know par excellance and I think Trump
what Trump did is he brought his
background as a real estate developer
where you're you're you're in New York
you know in the the thick of it whether
you know he had a track record some
people liked his track record some
people didn't like his track record but
he built big things he built big
buildings you know he built
Hotel Empire and in those real estate
negotiations I I used to see this as a
lawyer with with clients you you've got
to keep two things in mind at the same
time and it's hard for a lot of people
to understand that you're trying to do a
deal with someone and you're trying to
beat the heck out of them and get get
the best price you can and at the same
time they're a partner because you you
want them to consummate the deal right
so you want to get if you're if you're
buying land from somebody or buying a
building you want to get the very best
price but at the same time you want to
keep them at the table and have not go
to other guy and sell the building to
someone else because you want that asset
and or if you're selling the same thing
just on the other side of the table I
think president Trump learned that you
know through years of negotiations in in
real estate 50 50-year career and and
even younger than that watching his dad
Fred Trump you know do deals that you
know you got to be tough and you got to
get get the best deal you can but at the
same time you got to prevent your
partner from walking away from the the
deal and walking away from the table and
striking that balance I think is pretty
tough and and look a lot of people don't
have experience with it a lot of people
come come into government from think
tanks or from Academia or or from the
military where folks are used to Falling
orders uh or or even as lawyers but you
know maybe without the the litigation or
the the deal
experience so they come to to government
and people expect them to be great
negotiators but they've never really had
that that experience whereas president
Trump came to office probably with more
experience negotiating you know that
certainly anyone in his cabinet anyone
in his his immediate circle but also any
other politician in the world that he
was dealing with so for for good or For
Better or For Worse I mean there you
know there are all kinds of different
ways to prepare to be president I'm not
saying being a real estate developer is
the best way to prepare to be president
but for for president trump it worked
when it came to these negotiations that
we've been talking about and and and
trying to come to a deal where you get
both parties to say yes but you get a
good deal for America and so I think
that's probably the the the the best
preparation he had for some of the
things we've been talking about Jordan
well you've worked as a diplomat and a
litigator and National Security advisor
and all of that's involved negotiation
and you know one of the things I've
noted in my private life watching people
and in my clinical practice and suppose
in my role as a as a
professor as well is that generally
speaking people are very bad at
negotiating they don't say what they
want they don't admit what they want
they don't listen to the other side they
don't understand how to strike that
playful balance between competition and
keeping their partner in the game um
they're not trained to negotiate we do a
very bad job of that in our society
people can't negotiate with themselves
they can't negotiate with their spouses
they're not good at negotiating with
their kids they can't strike a deal with
their business partners like it's a big
problem right because negotiation
there's no difference
between bringing a successful
negotiation to a conclusion and
establishing peace those are the same
things now you've done a lot of
negotiating and as a diplomat which is
more diplomatic obviously as a litigator
which is more on the offense side let's
say and then under stressful conditions
when you're negotiating for hostage
release what is it that you've seen
that makes a successful negotiator what
skills do you have to master and what
pitfalls do you have to avoid and how
have you mastered that or have you you
know do feel that you've mastered it
well I I certainly haven't mastered it
but uh I have had a fair amount of
experience and uh you know sometimes
successfully negotiated deals or or
releases or diplomatic Accords and
sometimes unsuccessfully it uh so it uh
certainly not 100% track record it's
it's a big question and there's a lot
that goes into that mix and you talk
about all the different scenarios in
which we're involved in negotiation
whether it's in our home life our
business life or professional life
putting it totally aside
politics and and international Affairs
we're all negotiating all the time I I
think there are a couple of of things
that that have been load stares for me
in in negotiating is one is
understanding that the other party has
to get something out of the negotiation
and that doesn't mean money necessarily
it doesn't mean uh you know but but it
usually means respect uh so I think
being respectful and being cordial with
your adversary even if there a you know
I've sat across the table from some some
pretty uh uh unsavory characters but if
you're respectful and you're cordial uh
that that that's one thing that you can
give that cost you
nothing other than you know some
Goodwill and some uh some humility uh so
that's number one number two you have to
listen to the other side and try and
figure out what is it they really want
because they may be saying they want one
thing but they really want something
else and figuring out what they what
their you know bottom line is what what
what's what's the least amount they'd
take to give you what you want requires
you to listen to them uh number three I
think you have to be honest I mean I I
I've never done a negotiation in in my
private life or in as a lawyer as a
litigator as a diplomat where I've lied
to people I just don't think I may not
disclose every all the information I've
got or that I know but I don't lie to
people because once once you get caught
out in a negotiation telling something
is false or lying you you've lost your
credibility and your ability to to get a
deal done goes
away and I think the last I'd make him
response to that question and again
probably a hundred if we sat and thought
about it and talked longer you've got to
be willing to say no there has to be a
point at which you'll walk away from the
table because if if there's not
some level that you'll say no and walk
away You're your opponent will
understand that and they'll push and
push and push until they've taken
everything from you you've got to have a
red line and and sometimes it's hard
because you've you know saying no is
going to mean somebody staying in prison
longer or somebody you know being in a
dungeon longer or not getting the the
the deal you really wanted for you know
your your client if you're a litigator
not getting the peace deal that would
you know make the headlines and and and
help solve a war but if you're not
willing to say no and your adversary
doesn't understands you're not willing
to say no there's no limit to what
they'll take from you and so you have to
have you have to have your own and that
doesn't mean you have to disclose those
red lines and and tell them what you're
going to say no and that's kind of the
interplay with the the honesty issue but
you got to be able to say you know
oftentimes you're ambiguous about it
where you tell the other side there's a
point that I'm not going to go beyond
and you're getting close to it and if
you get to that point I'm going to get
up from the table I'm going to walk away
and then you're going to lose
negotiation as well because the point
that the look they're there because they
want something from you as well it's not
you coming as a supplicant usually you
know they're they're there not
supplicating to you you're not
supplicating to them but there's a deal
to be had you know how how that deal
works out you know you have to see but
but if they know that you're not willing
to get up and leave uh you're never
going to get a negotiation done I had
this happen and I'm not going to mention
the the country but we're involved in
pretty high stakes negotiations when I
was National Security
advisor and we thought we had a deal
with the leader of the country and we we
came back to finalize it and the the
foreign minister and some of the other
other leaders kind of tried to put new
conditions on try to renegotiate the
deal and and I did something at the time
I was a little tired had been long
nights and couple days straight I just
packed my briefcase and I had a whole
team of State Department folks with me
and I don't think they'd ever seen that
before and I packed up my briefcase and
said okay thank you we tried we gave it
our best shot but we're done and got up
and started to walk away and I think the
other side was shocked by it certainly
the guys from the the career officials
of the state department were looking at
me like I was a nut and I said come on
guys let's go we're out of here and uh
and the other side said wait wait wait
wait wait you know we then we got back
to the deal we had the night before with
the leader and uh but they they you know
our state department guys had never seen
someone pack up a briefcase and leave
well I I'd seen people pack up their
briefcases and leave a hundred times as
a lawyer in Los Angeles you know that
was if and and and usually if a good
plaintiff's lawyer didn't pack up his
bags and leave three or four times
during the day during a negotiation then
you weren't doing a good job so it uh uh
so so you got you got to be willing to
to walk away from the table if you if if
the other side's not serious and and
that doesn't mean you don't come back
you you laid out three principles there
that I think are worth delving into
because this is very important I think
for people's practive lives as well so
well I learned something very profound
from Carl Rogers and a lot of Rogers
clinician a lot of Rogers work has been
instrumental in establishing mediation
processes over the last few decades and
Rogers delineated out uh what's come to
be known as active listening which is
kind of a cliched version of what he was
attempting to put forward and I've used
this a lot in my private life and also
in my clinical practice um because it
actually works it's one of the few
psychological techniques so to speak
it's not manipulative that I that
actually is credible and not just
cliched
Rogers suggested to the people he was
attempting to inform the clinicians he
was trying to CH train that when they
listen to a
client that they listened with without
interruption and then provided back to
the client a summary of what they had
just said and asked the client whether
or not that summary accurately
represented the intent of the
communication and that was useful in
three ways say the first element of
utility is that it indicated that at
least that the listener was interested
in and attentive enough to fully and
brave enough to fully understand what
was being communicated so that's very
useful because that's a sign of respect
right attentive respect the next part of
it that was useful was to indicate to
the person that what had been said was
actually understood right because if
you're going
to put the gist forward you have to have
understood it and that also often helped
the person who was committ communicating
clarify what it is that they were
actually trying to communicate because
it's not always the case that the person
you're talking to knows exactly what
they want and so you're offering them a
gift if you can summarize it and then
you also have some insight into the
potential conditions of
satisfaction that the under other person
is attempting to establish like if I'm
talking to my wife one of the things
about something where there's some
contention and we've we've negotiated
this as a meta negotiation strategy is
that it's incumbent on both of us to say
to define the conditions under which
peace could theoretically Prevail you
know because you can ask someone well
what would I have to give you
hypothetically so that this went away
and you were happy now I it isn't
necessarily the case that I can or will
deliver that but at least I'd like to
know right okay so that's active
listening and then you said also and
condition of satisfaction you also said
this is something I always told my
clients too is that if you can't say no
you can't negotiate and then no means
this is what no
means no means if you continue doing
what you're
doing something you do not like will
happen to you with 100%
certainty now that might just be that
all leave and that the negotiation ends
but you know it could be other things as
well but if you don't have that in your
back pocket in the back of your mind if
there's no
line that that that you've put forward
that can't be crossed of course you
can't negotiate because the whole
negotiation is a lie because really what
you're doing is walking into the
situation saying I'm fully yours for the
taking but I'm going to pretend that's
not the case and if the person on the
other side is the least bit canny or the
least bit pushy like a good litigator
would be they're going to figure that
out by every nonverbal cue you put
forward by and by everything you say and
don't say so you need to listen so you
know what the person wants you have to
find out their conditions of
satisfaction to see if they can possibly
be met and then you have to determine as
you pointed out that you can and will
say no and that no actually means well
it means that something that isn't
Pleasant is going to transpire otherwise
you have no strength as far as I can
detail well no that's that's a great
summary and uh again you know I didn't
have the formal training from Rogers it
was more the uh kind of the School of
Hard Knocks of of litigating a lot of
cases and and working as a diplomat and
you know learning those experiences but
I think it's a great summary so 100% and
again I think that that being willing to
say no is is just critical folks have to
know that there is a a point and as you
you know you point out there's a point
of no return where the the the
unpleasant thing just be that the ne
negotiations end but it may be that
there's going to be a military strike it
may be that there's going to be economic
sanction uh I had this happen with a a
relatively well-known case I had I was
sent to Sweden to bring home an American
rapper named ASAP Rocky and it was
somewhat controversial because he was
being held by an ally it was a result of
a street
scuffle but we determined that he was
being held unfairly and the sweds didn't
like the fact that I was showing up as
the hostage onvoy in fact I remember one
one reporter was joking and uh as I was
walking into the courthouse uh are you
sending a carrier are you going to send
the seals and uh but we had to negotiate
with our Swedish partners and you know
they're they're a new NATO Ally and they
were close partners then but they had no
intention of negotiating with us I mean
they in their view was this is in our
legal system stay out of it he'll get
dealt with as we see fit but the problem
is the president of the United States to
put our credibility on the line the
president said he's wrongfully detained
we're going to bring him home he thought
he had to deal with the Swedish prime
minister the Swedish prime minister saw
it a different way which that that that
that happens or miscommunications and no
no blame on on the to the sweds but I
had to sit down and and Mike Pompeo
wrote about this in in his books I'll
I'll mention it because secretary Pompeo
mentioned it when Mike sent me I was a
hostage Envoy at the time sent me to
Sweden he said listen you got cart
blanch you can use whatever economic
tool you want you know tell them they're
never going to sell another Volvo in
America and and so at that point even
though the the swedes weren't prepared
to negotiate when we kind of said we
understand that and that's in fact I
actually told the deputy foreign
minister that's quite admirable that
you're you're willing to stand up to the
US you're not going to negotiate but you
know this is important to us now because
I've got hostages all over the world
I've got hostages in Lebanon and Syria
and Iran and Venezuela and North Korea
if we cave to SW Sweden because and and
and don't get the result the president
said we're going to get our credibility
is shot around the world for you know
dealing with other regimes are going to
say if the swed can push you around well
we're far Naser than the sweds are uh
we'll do the same I said so I understand
your point of view and uh it's it's
admirable uh but you're never going to
sell another Ville in America and so so
you you know there going to be factories
in America that you built and factories
in in Sweden that you built then that
won't have you know you're F the fire
thousands of Swedish workers and if if
you know you've got to decide what's
more important to you at this point you
know keeping this rapper who you've who
was attacked by some some Afghan
migrants and they' kept that out of the
press you know and uh and fought back
and and you know lesson learned for
those guys don't attack a rapper in his
posy not not a good idea in a street
fight uh but you know if it's so
important you you put him in jail for a
year or two and in a kind of a dubious
situation their argument was that he
defended himself but then you know the
longer the fight went on it you exceeded
his self-defense rights but I said on a
on a relatively du be a thing that would
never even be charged in a place like
Los Angeles and it wouldn't even get to
the DA's office the police would have
dealt with it and uh I I said and it's
so important you're going put close down
some of your factories to to maintain
that principle and you know God bless
you and uh we we saw a newspaper article
come out a day or two later that said
the US is bullying Sweden we knew it was
leaked by the swedes because we didn't
uh disclose it and so I knew at that
point that they'd probably made the
decision they'll blame the US for
bullying them and that was fine I me I
wanted wanted them to be able to stay
face and Sweden's a great country they
were helping us in North Korea we I
remember meeting with the for become
National Security adviser a couple weeks
later I met with a foreign minister who
was a really impressive woman and we had
a had a great meeting on North Korea we
let bygones be got bygones with the ASAP
Rocky case and uh but but again you have
to it's easy for a party to come to the
table and say I'm not negotiating with
you I get everything I want and if
you're willing if if that's what you're
going to do then just pack up your bags
and go home or don't even show up at the
negotiation but if you're going to if
you're going to try and get the result
you want and your credibility is on the
line then you've got to be willing to to
to let people know that there is a
consequence that comes with a no like
you can say no but there's a consequence
that comes with it and and in that case
we were able to get the whole thing
resolved Sweden convicted them and then
let him go for time sered so they they
say face their justice system was was
able to run its course we I stayed for
the trial and after the trial ASAP was
able to get home and and come back to
America and it all it all worked out
very well we maintained cural relations
but it's an example of a negotiation
where where both sides were pretty well
dug in and it didn't look like there was
a way to get it get it done but we we
got it done so on the on the with regard
to when you should say no so and this is
tied up very tightly with the issue of
honesty I think it's incumbent on you to
say and indicate know when you're
convinced of the fact that the
alternative position what you're going
to accept instead is actually an
untenable solution in the long run like
if you if you exceed to a negotiation
but you walk away bitter and resentful
and you believe that the conditions that
you now have to abide by are not only
unjust but unlikely to be maintained
then you should have said no more
harshly during the negotiation and that
does take a certain amount of
forthrightness and willingness to
confront and also the kind of honesty
that has a long-term view right I mean a
successful negotiation should also
appear to be should be and appear to be
just to both sides because otherwise
it's going to be undermined in all sorts
of secretive ways as soon as the
negotiation concludes well the old
saying in in you know La litigation
circles was you know it wasn't a good
deal unless both sides walked away
unhappy uh you know it's I think another
way of of restating what you just said
where both sides feel that they had some
sort of win and I'm not talking about a
Chinese you know the Chinese talk about
win-win negotiations and it's always the
Chinese win and you lose but uh but a
real win-win negotiation uh not not a
propaganda one uh you know you you both
sides need to come away with something
but when it gets to your issue of no and
and you you you're just a really good
point
Jordan you can say no in a negotiation
that doesn't mean we're done with
negotiating you can say no that that's
not a good deal I don't I don't want
that but let's keep going but when you
you get to that ultimate no that that
needs to be your Bedrock because you
don't want to say no and walk away and
think you know I could have actually
given a little bit more and gotten to
where I needed to be you need to be
honest with yourself about where is it
too painful for me to continue but where
where you know I may say no because I
don't like the deal and try and get a
better deal uh but but where where where
where's the no come that where you pack
up your briefcase and you literally walk
away and you're not coming back and that
that you have to prepare for that before
the negotiation and and and and know
what you're internally that doesn't mean
you share it with the other side but you
have to know internally what what are my
redlines and where can I where what's
that point where I I can't jump off the
cliff and and and commit suicide but you
know how close can I get to the cliff
and still get a deal I can I can be
happy with and and that's something you
have to you have to think about that
before you get before you start the
negotiation right right well when I was
working with people who were involved in
cellary negotiations for example there
were often people who had worked worked
quite diligently that weren't very good
at reporting what they had done to their
superiors that were laboring under some
degree of bitterness and resentment
because they didn't feel that their
contributions had been recognized and
perhaps rightly so we would always
ensure that before they went and had a
conversation with their boss that their
CV was in order and they'd already
checked out the alternative job market
and they had at least a lateral move in
mind and maybe a better move and then
we'd Pro the conversation so that they
knew exactly what they were saying but
the reason for them to get their CV in
order and so forth was because they
needed to walk in there knowing that
they could tell their boss to that they
would leave now they didn't want to you
know that that was an outcome but if
they didn't have that in their back
pocket they were weak and if they did
have it in their back pocket they're
much more effective negotiators they
knew what they wanted and they knew
where their line was and that stiffened
their spine in the and you have to have
all that straight in your head before
you go into to the negotiation no this a
great Point what I used to tell people
and uh and still do tell colleagues who
are thinking about leaving their job or
aren't happy or think there's a better o
opportunity I always tell them keep one
arm on the monkey bar when you're
swinging for the other one but don't
don't drop it in the air and hope you're
going to catch the other Monkey Bar make
sure you've got make sure you've got a
make sure you've got a plan B you've got
another job or you can keep your current
job but don't don't drop the Monkey Bar
and hoping hoping you have enough
momentum to get the the next rung it may
work uh but you could also end up in the
sand pit down on your butt right well it
helps as well so you know it helps very
much as well to walk into a
negotiation having plotted out what
you'll do if it goes as badly as it
could right because there's going to be
fears that beset you what if this is a
catastrophe and the answer to that can't
be oh it won't be a catastrophe the
answer has to be if this is a
catastrophe here's the steps that I will
take to ensure Victory on a different
front and that also stops you from being
pushed around yeah yeah 100% how do I
how do I mitigate the downside
and and look it helps to have a
counselor you know and I'm not just
talking about a national security
adviser it helps have someone like you
or or a lawyer or a psychologist or a
friend or your wife that you can sit
down before the negotiation and talk
these things through because sometimes
it's it's hard to do it on your own so
if you've got people you can rely on
whether it's colleagues or or
professionals that you can bring in to
help in the negotiation and you walk
through these things you know you can
you can become more focused and figure
out you know here's my real red line if
I have to walk away with that red line
here's the downsides to me how do I
mitigate them and here's how I can
here's how I can give the other side
down you know here's how I can you know
prepare downsides for the the opponent
you know so that they've got to keep
that in mind when they're negotiating
yeah well it's also very helpful to
pre-negotiate with people who are quite
pushy so that they can push your limits
and test you out and that's actually
part of the purpose of critical thinking
right is you could have all the
weaknesses in your position analyzed by
you know without any real threat except
maybe to your self esteem and your ego
you know in with your inability to
formulate your arguments clearly but
it's a hell of a lot better to have them
pretested than to have them fail on the
actual
Battlefield 100% absolutely so you
characterized earlier and this will be a
lead into some questions about Russia
you characteriz characterize the
withdrawal from Afghanistan as
catastrophic and so that's all faded
away in principle although we may be
suffering from the aftermath of that in
the form of this you
know NeverEnding conflict or a conflict
that looks like it's going to never be
ending in in Russia and Ukraine why
would you characterize the withdrawal in
Afghanistan as catastrophic I mean the
US did extract itself it was was a messy
long-term
conflict um
so in that way it's come to an end and
you could imagine that there might be
some benefits from that but that
obviously that isn't the way that you
look at it
overall and so what is it about the
withdrawal that you object to and why
did you characterize it as
catastrophic so so let me walk you
through that but let me first make a
point when you when you said it faded
away and you're right because we've got
a short attention span in the west it's
not just America it's can Western Europe
Japan Australia well what I kind of call
not the geographical West but the the
ideological West hopefully India is
becoming part of that that group and
other countries but we've got a short
attention span we go quarter to quarter
with our stocks we we go election to
election two-year cycles for the House
Representatives here four years for
president we've got a short yeah kind of
shortterm view and uh I think that's
true with Afghanistan and so people have
already forgotten you know that this
this just just happened and two years
ago but guess who doesn't have a
short-term view the Chinese Communist
party so when I was in Taiwan in March
of this year led a delegation there to
for GTI Global Taiwan Institute to work
on how how do we improve us Taiwan
relations and how can we strengthen
Taiwan and make it more resilient to
deter China One of the the things that
they had the videos that they showed on
Tik Tok and on Instagram to to undermine
the confidence of the people in Taiwan
in the relationship with the us but also
in their own you know ability to defend
themselves is they showed a picture of
that c17 that was running along the
Afghan the the the runway at Hamed carai
airport in downtown of
Kabul and had the Afghans running
alongside it and people climbing on the
wing and people trying to get in the
wheel well and uh they said this is what
what America will do to you this is how
America leaves this is you you'll be in
essence you'll be these poor Afghans
running along trying to hop on the
American airplane as they take off off
you better cut a good deal with us now
because this is your future and so that
that Afghanistan withraw that we might
might want to forget and you know you
know forget the 12 or 13 gold star
families who lost their their loved ones
at Hamed K Kai airport and the the
suicide bombing and we want that all all
that to go away uh our adversaries
aren't forgetting it and so it was you
know seen those videos embolden Putin to
go into Ukraine but it's also the
Chinese are very skillfully using it to
to undermine the confidence of our
allies in Asia about our ability to
stand with them in the event of a
Chinese Invasion so in other words cut
the good deal with us now because
America won't be there but going to your
broader question why was it a
catastrophe you know we wanted to get
out of Afghanistan that was a Forever
War secretary Pompeo and Ambassador
kalilo had spent a lot of time for
president Trump negotiating uh a deal
with the Taliban which we signed in
February of of
2020 and that deal was stopped killing
Americans because the president had
gotten sick of going to do and was sick
from going to do and I was with them on
three occasions I represented him on
another three occasions for the
dignified transfer of the remains of our
fallen heroes and you'd have to go on
and comfort those families and and watch
these young men come home and there were
no women at the time in my experience
but these young men coming home in a
flag drip casket and it was a beautiful
dignified transfer but that's not the
way their parents or their loved ones or
their wives wanted them to come home and
that's that's not the way America wanted
them to come home and uh and th those
are heart-wrenching experiences and we
decided look we got it we've got to end
this Afghanistan war it's taking number
one it's taking too many of our Lives of
our young men young women who are
volunteer to go serve our country and
defend ourselves defend America but and
it wasn't just America it was Canada
that was there and France and and many
of other partner Nations uh but it was
also costing us billions of dollars
every month and while we were plunging
billi millions of dollars into
Afghanistan with very little return I
Afghanistan was not on we mentioned
Sweden earlier Afghanistan was not on
the way to becoming the new Sweden uh
the Chinese were taking those same
billions of dollars and launching a new
frig or new destroyer every month so
they were engaged in great power
competition building the biggest Navy in
the world which they now have bigger
than the US Navy and we were pumping
this money into Afghanistan much of what
was getting put on pallets and cash and
being shipped to Dubai and because of
the corruption there uh and we had it
had to come to an end but it had to come
to an end in a way that that met
American national interests and so what
we what president Trump ultimately
decided and that took a lot of time to
get there is that we'd leave 2500 troops
there as a counterterrorist force to
deal with Isis K to deal with Al Qaeda
we had 5,000 NATO troops so for the
first time when when we left office in
January January 20 2021 we had 5,000
NATO troops and only 2,500 American
troops so we had two to one NATO
contribution to America NATO was bearing
the burden we were supporting NATO with
with exquisite capabilities but NATO was
bearing the burden we kept BM Airbase
because bogram had big fields of fire it
couldn't be overrun by the Taliban it
would have been the perfect place if we
ever had to engage in a somewhat uh
expedited withdrawal BM was a place to
do it so we we put everything in place
and then we insisted to the Taliban that
you have to negotiate with the Afghan
government that you know this can't be
we're not turning the government we're
not turning Afghanistan over to the
Taliban you've got to negotiate with
with your your friends you know
Frenemies your your fellow Afghans and
you got to have a government of national
unity and we're staying here until that
happens and even after that happens
we're likely going to stay because
you're going to need our help which the
Taliban is now even admitting with Isis
K I mean Isis K that with the alqa
offshoot which is just a brutal
terrorist organization is Alive and Well
in Afghanistan and and you know it's bad
when the when the Taliban are calling
them extremists
you know it's you know it's pretty bad
when the Taliban are saying hey those
those guys are Islamic extremists you
know it's just got to be pretty bad
that's they're they're now taking hold
in Afghanistan so so had we gone with
our plan kept a counterterrorism force
there had the Afghan government and
Taliban come together as a government of
national Unity used American Prestige
but hard power to make sure that
happened that would have been a very
different result than what we saw of of
Afghans falling out of wheel wells and
to the plunging to their death at hammed
carza airport
the leaving behind thousands of of of
Afghan collaborators who work with our
interpreters or Afghan Special Forces
Afghan Pilots leaving behind hundreds of
Americans I me there are still Americans
trapped in Afghanistan and that gives
the Afghan the Taliban leverage over the
administration you know in every
negotiation they have to free up funds
or that sort of thing because they've
got these Americans there and they've
got our our allies who are still there
that they could you know do do harm to
uh so you know it it was a very
different scenario that we had in mind
than what what played out and what
played out led to what we talked about
at the the top of the show is this
perception of American weakness that
we're so weak that we're running out
with our tail between our legs with the
shinook helicopters going to the top of
the embassy and EXT extracting our
diplomats and racing them to safety
while our Afghan allies suffered the
results of a Taliban takeover and again
you know maybe the Biden Administration
didn't expect it to happen maybe they
didn't expect the the the government of
Afghanistan to fall as quickly as it did
but you could see in hindsight you know
which is always perfect you can see how
just one step after another withdrawing
our our troops down to 600 troops giving
up bogram Airbase in the middle of the
night without telling our allies uh you
know appeasing the Taliban uh you know
begging them not to take this city until
a certain number of days you know that
that's the sort of thing that led to
this catastro
catastrophe and as Church Hill talked
about with with the Munich Accords this
is something that was going to carry on
with us long long down the road it was a
defeat without a battle and we're seeing
that now with Xi Jinping and Taiwan
we're seeing it with with the Ayatollah
uh in in the Middle East and we were
certainly the most concrete example is
we're watching Vladimir Putin you know
uh invade Ukraine and with limited
success but also with it causing great
and terrible humanitarian damage in
Ukraine and and basically to his own
people as well his own soldiers who they
lost thousands of young Russians lives
have been lost in in that meat grinder
so you know all of these things you can
tie back to what happened in Afghanistan
and then so in hindsight it was a really
poor decision by the bid Administration
to to handle the evacuation and the the
withraw the way they did ending the war
good idea doing it in that fashion bad
idea well given that that plan was in
place to keep 2500 troops there and that
there were 5,000 NATO personnel there as
well and that that would have been a
credible peacekeeping and deterrent for
Force why do you think the Biden
administrated Administration acted
contrary to that plan and so
precipitously yeah it's I I think there
were they there was just bad analysis I
think they thought the Afghan government
could stay in power longer than it did
that they they could get out quicker uh
I think they they didn't quite
understand the the the structure that
we'd Left Behind although we briefed him
on it many many times and so you heard
things like well this is Trump's fault
and Trump signed the deal Trump did have
a
plan look I think part of it goes back
to what we talked about earlier was was
Trump's resolve I mean the Taliban knew
not to push Donald Trump very far that
they knew the results of of what you
know that he'd take they saw the B daddy
right they saw you know how tough we
could be around the world uh I think
they took had a very different measure
of of Joe Biden and uh so I think all
these things played in played into it
and uh look I think another part is
Biden always wanted to get out of
Afghanistan I mean as as did we he
wanted to get out of Afghanistan back in
the Obama
Administration down Victory yeah well
and wanted I think they also wanted to
see a like a quick accomplishment on the
foreign policy side and that beckoned
let me let me talk to you now about the
situation in Russia and we talked a
little bit about what led up to it
although there's a lot more to
unpack with regard to that I mean I see
our relationship I guess we could talk
about that a bit I see our relationship
with Russia since the 1990s as an
unbroken string of missed opportunities
virtually unbroken string of missed
opportunities by the west and I also
don't understand what we're looking for
what our conditions of satisfaction
would be in relation to the current War
so this is how it appears to me in the
'90s after the wall collapsed there were
all sorts of attempts to modernize the
Russian economy um often conducted by
economists
who were out of their depth because
modernizing an entire nation's economy
uh bringing it into the capitalist realm
is complicated Beyond anyone's
understanding you need a Bedrock of
trust between people before that can
even happen and it's not easy at all to
understand how to instantiate that trust
right I mean in the west we assume that
the default economic transaction will be
honest and that's an absolute miracle I
have no idea how we ever accomplished
that because it's so unlikely that
distant people on eBay for example can
conduct transactions without attempting
to rip each other off the fact that
that's the case is an absolute bloody
miracle in any case the it looked to me
like we had an opportunity to bring the
Russians fully into the Western fold and
I think that by applying a cold war
mentality to that
situation either by commission or by
Omission consistently for 30 years we
squandered that opportunity now I know
that people view Putin as having
expansionist proclivities and that may
well be the case if you look at what
happened in Crimea and the dabass but I
also think that Russians regarded
Ukraine as an extension of Russia
and we're very concerned about NATO
incursion into Ukraine and it isn't
obvious to me and I'm perfectly willing
to be corrected uh in relationship to
this it isn't obvious to me that it
isn't obvious to me why we didn't try to
bring NATO into or to bring Russia into
NATO too especially given that the
fundamental concern that we're going to
be dealing with in the long run is
clearly China and now Russia and China
are much closer than they might have
been and that's further Complicated by
the fact that we're settling down into a
very long War here we're going to spend
the sort of money that we spent in
Afghanistan that could have been put
towards strengthening the Navy for
example we're going to spend the
billions of dollars in Ukraine that we
were spending in Afghanistan there and I
don't see what we have as a plan for
either peace or Victory so that's a lot
of things to throw at you but but it's
quite a mess so that is there is a lot
of things to to be thrown there so
anything you have to say that would
bring some clarity to that would be more
than welcome well there's a lot time
packed there and a lot of good thoughts
uh I I think starting at the beginning
how we dealt with Russia after the fall
of the wall and and we missed
opportunities but I think the Russians
missed a lot of opportunities too I
think a lot of times in the west we're
very critical of ourselves if we would
have only done this then they would have
you know responded reasonably I mean
Russia was a very corrupt Society it had
just come off a you know over you know
the re Revolution was in uh 18 so you
know basically 80 years of tyranny of
Soviet tyranny of the most brutal kind
purges and famines and millions I mean
tens of millions of people being killed
so there there's no surpris that the
fabric of the society across the former
Soviet Union was was frayed and there
wasn't the trust that you talked about
and by the way I agree with you it's
still a miracle that you can do a deal
in on eBay and and most of the time on
Craigslist or something most of the time
it works out it's it's shocking yeah
it's like 99% of the time yeah it's it's
it's and it's a testament to to you know
that that our system works and uh and
when we have faith in our system it will
work and for the benefit and prosperity
of all but Russia didn't have that and
uh I think the other issue is you know
Russia was an Empire and Britain
acquired an Empire and then gave it up
Russia has always been an Empire there
was the Russian Empire there was no
differentiation between Russia itself
and its colonies and its constituent
republics so you know they're assembled
in the Soviet Union but it was basically
the Russian Empire and I think the
Russians really struggled with the idea
that you know what Ukraine is just not
that into US I mean if you go to Ukraine
yeah it was it was subjugated by Russia
and there were Russians speaking people
in Ukraine but most ukrainians were were
were Western they were they been at one
point the Austrian hungaryan Empire the
Polish Empire or you know polish
Kingdom or you know they were Roman
Catholics to a large extent not not
Orthodox and so they didn't want to be
part of Russia and I think that was very
hard for the Russians to understand just
like a guy who's pining after a girl she
like she's Just Not That Into You the
ukrainians just aren't into that into
the Russians the the bals the
lithuanians the lvans the estonians not
that into Russia didn't want to be part
of the Empire they'd been subjugated and
so but it was very hard for the Russians
to understand that some of these
countries that they subjugated and and
dominated didn't want to be part of them
and and I I think that was a failure on
the Russians part uh so you know we may
have you know there's a lot of talk
about NATO expansion we tried to bring
Russia into NATO we had a part a nator
Russian partnership the Russians had
Military Officers in NATO headquarters
which you think now is quite shocking
you know in 2023 but you know in 200 you
know two that seemed like a great idea
and and unfortunately the Russians
didn't take advantage of that and I
think the Russians are being very
shortsighted and this is something I
pointed out to to patev when I
negotiated with him in Geneva a big part
of Russia and Russia's wealth is in the
East which is underpopulated in Siberia
and in Eastern Russia it's it's where
their diamond mines are their Platinum
mines their oil their gas their Timber
uh Wildlife I mean their their massive
lands a lot of that territory was taken
or agreed to be transferred to Russia in
1860 under a a something called the
convention of P King or the Treaty of P
King about the time of our civil war
here in America China gave up thousands
and thousands of miles of AC and you
know millions of acres of land to the
Russians including the city of
vlasto but R all along Siberia resource
Rich lands that the Russians forced the
Chinese because they had the the Z Zar
was far more powerful than the Chinese
emperor at the time they forced the
Chinese to recognize that as all Russian
land now Xi Jinping has said many times
that the century humiliation will be
overcome by the Chinese people and that
they'll take every square inch of
property back that they believe was
theirs that they believe was
historically Chinese that's why you had
maau and the Hong Kong and sjan with the
wegers in western China it's why you see
them fighting the Indians today engaged
in bloody battles along the line of act
actual control in the Himalayas uh you
see it with
Tibet why you see it with t the threats
against Taiwan of course you know this
idea that they're going that China is
going to assemble all this land that it
lost to Western powers or it lost when
it was humiliated because it was weak do
you think they're not coming for the
Russian lands do you think they're not
coming for Siberia with its Treasure
Trove of of resources that the Chinese
are desperate for because the Chinese
are relative for as big a country as
China is it's bere of Natural Resources
the way that Russia or America has these
great stores of natural resources and
wealth they're coming for that and I
told that to the Russians and Tom Clancy
wrote a book about it you know years ago
at uh called the bar the dragon or the
dragon coming over the mountain or
something along those lines the the
Chinese are coming for that land and and
they're doing it very cleverly right now
there's I think N9 million people in
Eastern Russia three million of them are
illegal Chinese immigrants the Chinese
are flooding into Russia they they throw
a bottle of vodka at the Border guard
and you know get get let in uh and
they're going to take that Pro that land
back and that goes to this National
interest Russia's national interest is
not with China China look looks Russia
is being weak as being a country that
can be colonized or can be re reabsorbed
into China in large part and that can be
dominated by Xi Jinping the Russians are
proud people and and they they're not
they're no longer Communists they're
they're authoritarian they're
imperialists but they're not communist
they've got no ideological affiliation
with Beijing you know Vladimir Putin or
whoever comes after them you know the
one thing we know about Russians
throughout history that whether it's AAR
or the General Secretary of the
Communist party they don't like to get a
back seat to anybody as a Russian
they're very proud people I don't think
they're going to want to be a colony of
China and so you know unfortunately
what's happened is we you know I don't
want to say we've pushed the Russians to
Shina the r the Russians would tell you
the West has pushed the Russians China
but we needed to come up with a way and
we still need to come up with a way to
deal with Russia that doesn't allow them
to invade their neighbors doesn't allow
to invade Poland or Lithuania lvia
Estonia or Finland or or Ukraine but
that that PO them back away from this
Unholy Alliance that they've got with
with Beijing and how do you how do you
see that happen the Russians interest so
so what what H how do you see that
laying itself out given that this war is
devolving into well it's it's very
difficult to get accurate representation
of the situation but my understanding is
that it's turned into something like a
grinding stalemate with the advantage
possibly shifting to the superior
Russian forces now like I said I'm not
I'm not confident in in the information
that I have but what do you see
happening currently and how would you
outline something approximating a
productive pathway
forward well look I think you're you're
right in describing the situation and
this what I said that the ukrainians are
very uh tough and very svy at the
outside of the invasion and they they
really dealt the Russians a bloody
bloody nose one of the reasons they did
that was that because we got them in the
Trump Administration we got him 600
Javelin missiles anti-tank missiles that
were highly effective at blunting those
three armored axises that came into
Ukraine and uh you know up until that
time you know when I was National
Security advisor we were having a heck
of a time getting the Pentagon to even
deliver them to the those javelins to to
Ukraine because there were people in the
Secretary of defense's office that
didn't want to provoke Putin it goes
back to this whole theory that if we if
we give the if we help the ukrainians
we'll provoke Putin so after after
Russia invaded Ukraine the first time in
and took Crimea and took parts of the
dabass you know remember the Obama
Administration said we're going to Aid
Ukraine and we sent them Gatorade and
MREs and blankets and you know a few
night vision goggles and what they
needed you know was it's like zinsky
said this time when they offered to send
him a helicopter he said I don't need a
helicopter I don't need a ride I need I
need ammunition and we we got him the
ammunition to to blunt the initial
invasion they got more from the Biden
Administration I credit the Biden
Administration for doing that uh when it
came time but the Russians suffered but
what I've told people is the Russians
aren't stupid these are very smart
people these are technical people
they've got engineers and scientists and
doctors and you know musicians I mean
this is a a culture that's they they got
sput to space before we did uh so so
don't count the Russians out because
they're not dumb and and if you look at
Russia's Wars whether it was Sweden uh
or or France with Napoleon or or Germany
with Hitler the Russians always do
poorly at the outset and then because
they're willing to throw men and
material into the meat grinder in a way
that we can't do in the west because the
the political constraints aren't on them
they can they can go through 100,000
dead young men without losing the
presidency uh that wouldn't work here in
the west it wouldn't work in Canada or
America but it works in Russia and they
use it to their advantage Stalin did it
Putin's doing it now and and they're
between their smarts and their their
cruelty to their own people you they're
they're going to turn things around and
I think they've started to do that that
and so it's a uh you know we're in a
very very difficult situation for the
ukrainians so now the qu the big
question and I look I don't have the
answer on this Jordan but we need to
figure it out is how do we how do we
resolve this situation so the ukrainians
have a safe and secure country uh get
most of their territory back if not all
of it uh in the war give them security
guarantees and the ukrainians are going
to be skeptical of those guarantees
because they had the security guarant
from the US and Britain and Russia and
France and the Budapest Accords and you
know that didn't didn't help him out
that was aition for them giving up their
nuclear weapons right right which which
by the way now is this this whole thing
is another you know argument for any
country that's thinking about getting a
nuke is get a nuke because you know
that's the only that's the only real way
you can defend yourself against a great
power so it makes non non- proliferation
tougher uh and and and and counter
pration tougher so the question is how
do we get the ukrainians what they need
uh and the the security they need and
how do we get the Russians to to to back
off and pull them away from the Chinese
and and more integrate them more with
the EU and the west and and and try and
make them a responsible stakeholder and
player well especially because we need
much of what they have to offer I mean
the the the the world can't do as far as
I can tell without Russia SL Ukraine
natural resources on the particularly
with regard to fossil fuels but also
with regard to well the ammonia that
those fossil fuels produce that's a
crucial issue but also the amount of
edible grain that both of those States
produce and of course that's not the
their only contribution to the world's
economy I mean it's hard to defeat a
trading partner upon whose resources
you're actually dependent and I mean
it's terribly complex as you said I mean
Ukraine has to be supported because they
did give up their nuclear weapons and
that's obviously a bad thing if they
they give up their weapons and strip
themselves naked and now they have no
defense that's not a good precedent for
operating in the rest of the world I
mean I it doesn't look I'm speaking out
of turn here but I'm going to anyways
because you have to start somewhere I
can't imagine the Russians ever giving
up Crimea I think they'd I think they'd
go back to the wall to keep Crimea with
regard to the newer territories they
took over over their argument of course
is that those territories were primarily
occupied by Russian speakers who have a
primary allegiance to Russia and it
seems to me that that could be in
principle settled by something
approximating a referendum in those
districts if that was something that
could be established under International
supervision and then to provide the
ukrainians with territorial Integrity
guarantees and to invite the Russians
back into the western game looks to me
that something like that looks like a
pathway forward and maybe I've been
accused in my attitudes of being a
Russia appeaser and I'm certainly not
trying to do that I think I'm fairly
cognizant of the dangers of the Russian
Enterprise overall I think that makes me
more appreciative in some ways of Putin
than other people might be because my
sense is that by historical standards
Putin is by no means the worst and most
reprehensible leader that the Russians
have ever managed to produce and so you
know it might be lovely to consider what
the country would be like in his absence
but yeah it's a low bar for him that
that's for sure it's it's as low a bar
as as has ever been established anywhere
with the possible exception of the
Chinese so so anyways I mean those are
thoughts about what a what a potential
move towards solution might might
approximate I mean what do you think of
those thoughts and what do you think
there is as an
alternative I mean the Ukraine
ukrainians I think are going to become
increasing desperate and that also
brings up the terrible danger of having
the West Dragged In you know which is
the most likely outcome Dragged In by
their sleeve into this terrible
monstrous
machine well look I think a lot of good
points and and let me start with the
first thing you mentioned about the
trading partner look if if Russia could
get integrated like it was on on its way
to into the West selling oil and gas uh
and and agricultural goods and and the
agricultural goods are they may not be
that expensive may not be considered you
know cash crops or or the same as
diamonds or platinum or o oil and gas
but that agricultural output of Ukraine
and and Russ and Southern Russia that's
a bread basket of for Africa for
Southeast Asia for for Asia I mean with
without that we're we're going to face
famine and and it's critical that we get
this grain out of Ukraine and and a lot
the Russians to keep trading their grain
because there's so many people that will
just literally die in in places like you
know the Congo and Egypt and other
Lebanon that will'll have real trouble
if they can't get access to it the other
issue in you know Canada has something
in common with Ukraine and Russia here
is potach which you need for fertilizer
and and to grow crops on Industrial
scale Canada Russia and Ukraine and the
only folks that make potach to
commercially viable levels they can
allow for modern agriculture which has
kept the world from going to famine so
there there are a lot of important
things that you know to to the world in
getting this conflict resolved as far as
your you know the the kind of the pieces
or parts to a compromise or a settlement
or an accord that you laid out look I
think those are things that people are
talking about around the world uh the
ukrainians are smart they're thinking
about those issues the Russians are
thinking about them but I think what's
happened is there there hasn't been you
you can't get a negotiation if you can't
get the two people the two parties to
the table and right now Ukraine's not
ready to come to the table and Russia's
not ready to come to the table and I
think that the the other part of that is
we can't do the negotiations for them
the West is particularly bad at
negotiating for other countries and and
you know we're willing to you we we saw
this happen with Vietnam we saw it
happen with certainly with
Czechoslovakia and and Munich when
Chamberlain talked about these are the
far away places of which we know little
about uh so we'll just we'll just give
up the sudate land for the checks and
they'll be happy with it and we'll we'll
end of war and again remember that was
incredibly popular in Britain when
Chamberlain came home and said we had
peace our time that's now ridiculed
that's mocked that wasn't at the time at
the time he was met by huge crowds of
the airport he came into Commons the
House of Commons and had a standing
ovation bar five people Churchill and
four of his colleagues were the only
ones sitting in bipartisan labor and
triartisan the time liberal labor and
conservative stand inovation for
Chamberlain so appeasement can be very
popular for and we we've got to avoid
the temptation as America or the
Europeans to come in and tell the the
ukrainians what they have to do or or
negotiate with a deal a separate deal
with the Russians and impose it on
Ukraine we've got to have the two
parties if we want this to be
longlasting and we want to be stable
Russian Ukraine have to do the
negotiations we can counsel ukrainians
counsel the Russians uh support the
ukrainians as we have been you know
that's all important and that that those
are you know rightful roles for the EU
and for America and and uh Canada and
our NATO allies but we need to make sure
that we're not trying to negotiate for
someone else because that that won't
work and and
that'll end that'll end up with another
conflict down the road now what what
leverage do you think the US has given
its provision of arms to Ukraine to
entice or
compel which is more dangerous obviously
them to the negotiating table sooner
rather than
later with with Ukraine I mean certainly
it's the Diplomatic The Diplomatic the
economic the military support that
they're getting that's huge leverage
from the West on Ukraine but you don't
want to use that unrighteously or
unjustly I mean you keep in mind
Ukraine's been invaded the war crimes
have been committed in Ukraine entire
cities have been wiped out and maybe the
most pernicious thing that's happened in
Ukraine and I I know you did a show on
uh o recently and and the the uh sound
of Freedom movie a 100,000 Ukrainian
kids have been taken out of Ukraine and
sent back to Russia now I don't know if
this was for sex trafficking or for my
my my guess is is the Russians were
trying to improve their demographic
situation because the demography of
Russia is so bad that they get these
kids and they incorporate them into
Russian families and they end up with
100,000 more Russian kids and and
families and fathers and that sort of
thing down the road so Putin knows he's
got a problem but but that's think about
the parents of these kids who are
kidnapped and put with other families I
mean this is really dastardly you know
stuff that's happening in Ukraine so we
we've got to support them and we've got
to and we don't want to be unrighteous
in the pressure that we put on them but
if there comes a point where we we
believe the Russians are willing to come
to the table in a good faith Manner and
and we think we could res resolving the
Ukraine crisis could help pull Russia
away from China and and we could get a
long- lasting
solution then we do go to the ukrainians
I think and say look we've been with you
from the start we've given you hundreds
of billions of dollars in Aid uh we
think we evaluate this as being a real
opportunity to negotiate we'll be the
Brokers we're not going to let the
Chinese be the Brokers that's another
thing mistake that we made was letting
the Chinese take the take the lead in
peace negotiations that that should be
the US and the West job we'll sit down
with you we'll be the honest Brokers and
we'll help try and get a deal done and
look I don't know if this Administration
has the ability to do it for for a whole
number of reasons but I think a new
Administration whether it's president
Trump or potentially Des santis or
whoever it is could could come in with a
clean slate and and maybe lay the
groundw for that sort of a
negotiation but it's a uh it's a heck of
a challenge not just not just the
ukrainians who are bearing the brunt of
it and have paid the biggest price I we
spent a lot of money but they paid the
biggest price in in human sacrifice for
their soldiers Sam Sailors Samar and
Marines who've been killed by the
Russians and their civilians who've been
killed their children have' been lost uh
but it's it's it's you know it's been a
sacrifice for for everybody involved in
the conflict including you know third
party beneficiaries of grain from Russia
and Ukraine who aren't getting the grain
they need to to stay healthy in Africa
and the Middle East and in Asia so uh we
we need to figure out how to get this
thing to a resolution but I and you
you've talked about some of the outlines
of what could be a potential solution
but right now I I just don't see
anything that's going to bring the
parties to the table uh maybe if the
Ukraine offensive stalls if you know
there's a change in government here in
the US if there's a change in government
in Russia which I don't see happening
right away uh you know there there there
are variables that could could speed up
the process you know that we don't see
now but right right now things look
pretty bleak right right okay well let's
close this um I also wanted to talk talk
to you about the Abraham Accords their
their current status how you evaluate
them overall and how they might be
extended maybe you could just start by
reminding people who are watching and
listening what the Abraham Accords were
and what they signified and how it was
that they were successfully negotiated
which was somewhat of a miracle and then
what you
see them having produced and may still
be capable of yet producing well look I
think they it was one of the Great
accomplishments of the Trump
Administration but I think it's an
American accomplishment I don't think
it's just a trump accomplishment or a
you know Jared
Kushner Mike Pompeo or stepen uchin or
Robert O'Brien accomplishment I think it
was an accomplishment for our country
that we were able to to use America's
influence to bring peace and it goes
back to you what we talked about earlier
in the show about peace through strength
a strong America is good not just for
America but it's good for the world
because it allows for peace to to break
out the Abraham Accords originally
started out as a deal between the UAE
the United Arab Emirates and Israel to
bring peace to those two countries both
strong partners of the United States
both small countries but the small
countries have punched way above their
weight in international Affairs and
certainly in the region and every effort
to get peace in the Middle East up until
this time had been styed because the
idea was if Israel couldn't do a deal
with the Palestinians they couldn't do a
deal with any other Arab country so we
started out with Palestinians and we
gave them a proposed a great deal as a
the kind of neutral mediator in the the
deal we proposed a great deal with the
Palestinians we had to put a lot of
pressure on the Israelis to to accept it
uh the Palestinians was one Diplomat
once said never miss an opportunity to
miss an opportunity miss that
opportunity we were able to then have
the Israelis go to the the UAE and say
look we gave this awesome deal to the
Palestinians they turned it down why are
we going to why are you going to allow
them to to keep us from having a deal
keep us from having peace between our
two countries and it took took a lot of
negotiations with the Saudis and and uh
because none of this would have happened
without Saudi approval they the Saudis
didn't ultimately sign the deal but had
the saudi's been totally opposed to it
they it wouldn't have happened we did a
lot of negotiations with the UAE
Bahrain and we we I think the parties
made a courageous decision because it
wasn't just a political decision to make
peace it was a really a physical
security situation because we look at
what's happened to past leaders in the
Middle East that have made peace Sadat
or rabine or you know you can end up
dead very quickly and so I think it took
a lot of Courage from the Crown Prince
uh Muhammad B zad from uh BB Netanyahu
uh to the king of Bahrain uh to King
Muhammad in in Morocco who who all
entered into this peace deal and you
know it was improbable it was improbable
from the American side we had to pull
together our our whole team and you know
the the power that the National Security
adviser has Isn't So Much as a line you
don't have line Authority you can't
order people to do do things you can't
order ambassadors to do things that's
the state department that's the
Secretary of State you can't order
generals to do things that's the you
know Department defense and the
Secretary of Defense but you can convene
people and we brought together a great
team of Mike Pompeo and Secretary of
State and stepuchin and Jared Kushner
and and our team at the NFC and and
others we got that whole team all run on
the same in the same direction the same
boat uh which doesn't always happen in
the US government unfortunately and and
we and we got the president behind it
and you know we knew it was a long shot
I mean you know we we've been counseled
by very senior former officials that
said said don't waste your time with
middle east peace it's a it's a mirage
that everyone every Administration goes
for no one gets it and you waste all
your time and energy you know pursue
other priorities but we thought we could
get it done and and the parties took big
risks to to make peace the the Israelis
gave up you know settlements annexing
settlements in the West Bank the uh the
Arab countries risk their street rising
up or being upset with them uh they risk
potential terrorism from Iran or from
the
Palestinians but we got them together
and what does it mean I mean number one
militarily it's and intelligence wise
it's a great Alliance to these countries
or not quite a military intelligence
Alliance but a partnership against Iran
because Iran wants like like China and
Russia Iran wants to change how the
world operates and they want to place
themselves with their their Shia
ideology their end times ideology at the
top of the the region in the Middle East
dominate the Entre Middle East and
ultimately have great influence all over
the world and change the way we live our
lives and and this you know this Abraham
Accords took a very strong UAE a strong
Israel and other countries and put them
together and helped them stand up to the
Iranians so so number one militarily it
was a and and intelligence wise it was a
great deal number two
economically you know that we've got the
the most dynamic country in the world
outside of America outside of Silicon
Valley is Tel Aviv and Jerusalem then
Israel the the tech sector there both on
the hard tech side the the computers and
chips the soft side with software but
then the egg tech and and figuring out
how to make the Desert Blossom and and
grow the food that we need and to manage
the water which is you know going to be
as important is oil in the future that's
all coming out of this little tiny
country of Israel is just blossoming but
they need investment and so the UAE has
almost an unlimited amount of invest
Capital to invest they a very wealthy
country they've got very wellestablished
Capital markets you know all they're
they're the crossroads of trade and not
just for the Middle East but for Africa
and Asia so to put the UAE and their
capital and their trading expertise
together with the Israelis and their
Tech was is just a going to create an
economic D dynamism that it's not going
to be 1 plus 1 equals 2 it's going to be
1 plus 1 equals like five the benefit it
had for us as Americans is as we've
pushed the Chinese out of our Tech
sector with using the cfus process and
and other tools the Chinese were
starting to invest heavily in Israel
because they were going to you know the
Chinese are good at mimicking and and
and copying but they're not great at
innovating and so they were going to go
where the The Innovation was happening
well now what's happened is this Arab
Money this UAE money capital is being
invested in Israeli startups and it's
pushing the Chinese out of Israel which
is another great benefit to the United
States so You' got this military you got
this intelligence you got this economic
benefit but the the intangible is peace
for peace sake you know we always kind
of look at things in my world National
Security and foreign policy is how do we
advance American interests how do we
protect ourselves how do we keep
ourselves safe you know it's it's kind
of a hard analysis but but for human
beings every time I see a friend send me
an Instagram photo of somebody having
their Bat Mitzvah their Bar Mitzvah in
Dubai and say isn't this great it's
pretty amazing when you think about it
that this just happened you know three
years ago I mean September of 2020 and
you've got all these isra
kids wanting to go to their B Mitzvah
their Bar Mitzvah in Dubai I mean how
that that that's that's good for the
human spirit it's good for the soul when
when you see when you see amadis up on
the Temple mount in Jerusalem going to
the alxa mosque or the Blue Mosque and
making the pilgrimage to what they
believe is the third most holy site in
Islam and they can now go fly directly
from Abu Dhabi to uh to Jerusalem to
beneran airport and Tel Aviv and drive
up to Jerusalem up to the mountains and
and and go have their pilgrimage these
are things that were just that that were
unheard of I mean no one would have even
believed that they'd happened you know
even when I was a hostage onvoy and and
doing work in the region he would have
told me that there'd be the peace would
be breaking out you know it was it was
something that you wouldn't have thought
possible and yet it is and so there's a
human element and and example to other
places in the world that no matter how
intractable the problems are and maybe
even Russia Ukraine you know that that
you can you know come up with an accord
and and I'm proud of the United States
that we were the ones that brokered it
we didn't there was nothing we gained
directly from it we gained indirectly
obviously from the security and the
economics and the and just the Goodwill
for and Brotherhood of mankind but this
was us putting all of our political
capital on the line the president taking
big risk and putting his political
capital on the line uh you know our you
know departments and agencies don't
always get along well together playing
together to to to put make this push and
then you again I want to give credit to
the to Netanyahu and and Muhammad Ben
Zed and King Muhammad and you know the
others that actually signed the deal and
and put their own lives on the line it
was really qu quite an accomplishment
and and I hope there there's now some
talk that Saudi that the Biden
Administration is is pushing for the
Saudis to join the Abraham Accords I
mean put putting all politics aside it
would be great if Saudi joined the
Abraham Accords that would be tonin and
and Jake Sullivan and President Biden I
wish him luck because
be you know put put inside the politics
of how now of course President Biden
will get the Nobel Prize for it which
president Trump didn't get that's okay
well he should have got it the team
should have got it clearly but but it's
it's look it' be good for good for the
region good for the world and good for
America if Saudi joins the abramic cards
and if Saudi does then you're going to
have you know a good chance that Kuwait
and Oman and other countries certainly
some of them Islamic countries in Africa
will join and and I think you can have a
real you know kind of gold rush for
peace here and uh and change the way
that uh and and then hopefully the
Palestinians come along right and get on
board and and have their own State and
they're creative people they're smart
people doctors and you
know businessmen and and well educated
folks literate folks but they've been
kept down by these these leaders these
corrupt leaders in the Palestinian
Authority or the the Islamic extremists
in Gaza and if they get rid of the
corruption and the and the extremism the
Palestinians would have a chance for a
tremendous future in the middle e East
and a and a free and prosperous midle
Middle East so there's a lot of good
that can that's you know we did a lot of
good but there's a lot more good that
can happen and and I you know wish the
the Biden folks you know luck as they
pursue this the next piece which is is
clearly Saudi Arabia look that's a
really well it's very nice to be able to
end on a high note and and I do think
there's tremendous promise in the
extension of those Accords I mean and
and that would be a miracle of peace and
a miracle of economic expansion and and
man we could definitely use we could
definitely use more of that some Union
among the people of the abrahamic faiths
I know they're pushing that hard in the
UAE and so that that's a hell of a thing
to watch for and it's something
extraordinarily hopeful so yeah good
luck to the Biden Administration in
pursuing that if they can manage it that
would be real that would be very
forward-looking of them and to and and
also you know it require them giving the
devil his due and that would be Trump in
that situation but man the payoff would
be so great that you know you'd hope
people could lift their eyes above the
internet scene conflict U and and look
to the long run thank you very much for
talking to me today um thanks for having
me Jordan my my honor yeah it was a
pleasure it was a pleasure hearing from
you and and getting further educated on
the with regard to the issues that
you've you know been so involved in and
mastered to such a degree there's lots
of other things we could have talked
about and having said that I'm I'm going
to continue talking to Ambassador
O'Brien for another half an hour on the
daily wire plus side of things if those
of you who are watching and listening or
interested in that please join us there
uh we'll delve a little bit into the
more autobiographical more biographical
side of of uh Ambassador O'Brien's life
and so um you can join us there if you'd
like to otherwise thank you very much
for your time and attention here on
YouTube um and thanks once again for
agreeing to talk to me today it's a
pleasure great to be with you thank you
[Music]
Jordan